[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
it's a comedy podcast about death where
myself John Green and usually my brother
Hank green although not this week
because he is on paternity leave answer
your questions provide you dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon this
week I am so thrilled to be joined by
Ashley Ford hi Ashley
so tell us a little bit about yourself
right I like to put the self promo right
at the beginning so a hundred percent of
listeners hear it okay my name is Ashley
Ford obviously I'm a writer and an
editor and I do those things you know
sort of like freelance or as some people
want to be more fancy call it
self-employed and then during the day
I'm a development executive at a company
called matter studios and I work in
webseries and documentaries for them I'm
working on a book I write stuff on the
internet all the time and I'm just like
pretty much around like I'm just a ramp
actually I think one of the best follows
that you can possibly have on the
website Twitter but also I'm a huge fan
of your essays both memoir II and
otherwise and very excited for your book
I am familiar with that very problem I'm
living with it right now
so Ashley we've got to start the pod by
answering the question that we received
overwhelmingly over the last few days
which is one version or another of what
Oh God panic what how what do we do how
do I move forward from people who are
concerned about the results of the u.s.
election and I don't know what to tell
them you know it's it's really tough I
don't necessarily know what to tell
people right now which is
been strange for me because I am you
know I am that friend people usually
have who they call and they say I don't
know how to feel and I don't know what
to do and I can offer reassurances and
it was harder this time it was so much
harder I had a really hard time
reassuring myself I'm still not I would
say properly reassured the way I want to
be but you know I think at the end of
the day the thing that helps me sleep
and the thing that helps me get out of
bed when I wake up is the idea that I'm
one person but I'm one person with some
privilege and some power and some say
and I did what I was supposed to do I
showed up at the polls and I cast my
vote and my person didn't win but I
don't think that that's the last vote I
get to cast you know and I think I
actually cast votes every day with my
choices with my money with the things
that I share on social media I feel like
now more than ever I just need to be
conscious of how many votes I'm casting
and in what direction I'm like you know
hopefully influencing the country and
one way or another that was so beautiful
I have literally nothing to add to it
except to read a tweet that you wrote a
couple days ago that I found very useful
you wrote I'm feeling a lot of things
not all bad not all good kind of scared
and definitely nervous mostly I'm
committed to caring for myself
and the only thing I want to add to that
is that you know people need to take
care of themselves and you know take
care of yourself and remember like
Ashley said that every action that you
take is casting a vote it's very
beautifully put I have nothing to add
Thanks do you want to permanently
replace Hank he wouldn't have been
nearly as good in that one
because I love listening to the pot and
I love you guys's banter and you know
Hank it has such a particular way of
talking it is so fast and it is I know
like I know he talks so fast that you
think that he's smart you know what if
that's what he's doing it's working okay
because I'm usually like things happen
in the world and I'm just like you know
I'm really interested in how Hank is
going to respond to this because I know
he's going to say smart things and now
I'm really questioning whether or not
he's saying smart things or if I'm just
like sound smart I mean right I I think
he might be speaking very fast and it's
easy to mistake that it's easy to
mistake that for for intelligence all
right I want to ask you some questions
from our listeners and maybe maybe you
can ask me some as well since I know you
have access to the magical Google Doc
but I thought we could start with this
one
it comes from Caroline but I'm pretty
sure it doesn't actually come from
Caroline Ashley she writes dear John and
Hank I want to start off by saying that
I love your podcast thank you the reason
I'm writing to you is because I just
lost my class election for the senior
class secretarial position I'm feeling
very sad about the loss and even though
it was a close race I still feel as
though my classmates do not like me
enough to elect me to such a position
what do you guys suggest in order to
cope with this loss and how do I still
try to maintain a position to make my
senior year fun for my class now
actually I think we both know that
Hillary Clinton wrote this email as
someone who went to North Carolina to
talk to college students very suspicious
I called a lot of voters in North
Carolina in the five days before before
the election yeah it was fascinating to
talk to them I did I did greatly enjoy
my many conversations with undecided
voters in the days leading up to the
election so yeah I don't know what do
you say to somebody who is lost an
election that's very important
um you know I think that the beauty of
elections if there is a beauty is that
you really have to like be committed to
this idea that you might lose you know
like there's this thing you know like
the beauty of it isn't the in the
winning necessarily but it is in the
fact that people have a choice like
that's the beauty of an election is you
know the choice and knowing that people
get to have that choice and it doesn't
mean it doesn't hurt and it doesn't mean
that it doesn't smart a little bit but I
think you know I'm a realist who airs on
the side of optimism as a choice you
know and what I found that has been true
in my life is that any time I didn't get
the thing I wanted something better
eventually came along for me that I
would not have been able to take part in
had I gotten the thing that I thought I
wanted and yeah it ended up being better
for me in the long run and I'm not
saying that that's true for everyone and
I'm not saying that that's how it's
always going to go but I think there's a
chance and I think there's a lot to be
learned from our losses as well as our
wins and I think sometimes the lesson
isn't just ours I think sometimes a
person loses and the people who learn
from that situation are the people who
either didn't choose that person or the
people who didn't choose it all that's
again very good advice the only thing
that I would add to that in my life I've
definitely found that I learned more
from failures and losses that I learned
from successes but it often takes me a
while before I understand what I've
learned like in the moment it can be
very painful but then looking back on it
later I'm grateful for that experience
but I don't know how much it's matters
to me in the moment that later I'll be
grateful like I remember after I had
this horrible breakup just after the
terrorist attacks on 9/11
this woman and I have been living
together and we were you know thought we
thought we were gonna get married and
then we broke up and it was very very
difficult for me and I went through a
really hard time and I remember my
mother saying to me one day you will
look back on this as one of the greatest
things that ever happened to you and I
was like well maybe but not today and
I'm in today like I'm stuck in today and
today sucks so it does suck and I'm
sorry but I also I do think that there
there will be lessons to be taken from
it and you'll you'll grow from it
Caroline in college with someone who you
know we were looking at apartments
together and we were so in love and we
had never even had a fight and all of
these things and we got into one
argument and over the phone he said I
just don't want to be a boyfriend
anymore I was terrible like and it threw
me you know there are a lot of things
going on in my life at that point but
you know that one situation just threw
me into this really terrible depression
and it was the worst of my life and you
know for that was about seven years ago
and I have not since then felt anything
that died or felt anything that bad
until last week and suddenly in last
week that I was like that was the first
time I've ever felt truly grateful for
that bout of terrible depression from
2009 was last week because suddenly I
was looking at this depression that felt
you know or this feeling that felt
insurmountable and but it was so similar
to that thing that I had gotten over
before that I was able to be like oh no
now I know the way over like I know that
it's not easy but I also don't look
forward and think there's no way over or
I'll never know the way over it's like
no I've been here before and it sucks
that I'm back here but I can get out
like and I think that that's what's
really hard
in a moment especially when you're
hurting from something that you're not
used to dealing with is that you don't
know the way over yet and sometimes like
that is the lesson in that moment is now
you know the way over from this place
all right John I've got a question for
you
it's from Daisy I'm gonna read it right
now cool great dear Hank and John my
husband and I have been married for over
five years now together for eight and we
always said we would be ready for kids
at five years to give us time to enjoy
just being a married couple before we
start a family but five years has come
and neither of us feel well ready
like I want kids I want a family but I
don't have that I need a baby feeling
that I thought I would have but part of
me thinks that maybe that feeling will
never come I've never been a baby person
and so the choice to have kids might be
more driven by logic than desire like
this is a good time to start a family
rather than I want a kid now we are
starting to get the times ticking
comments from friends and family but I
don't want to make that important of a
decision based on others opinion how do
you know when you're ready to start a
family this is a tough one I think it
really obvious Lee it depends and it's
got to be a conversation with your
partner for us I don't think it was
really a profound feeling of like we
need to have a baby in our lives it was
to be honest at least for me like more
of a sort of I'm ready to enter that
part of my life now and I'm excited to
enter that part of my life now like we'd
moved to Indianapolis from New York and
we had a lawn and we had you know a home
and everything and there was a bedroom
there was nothing to do with the bedroom
Henry if you ever listen to this I want
to be clear that I did not bring you
into the world because we had a spare
bedroom but that's what we did we did
have a spare bedroom like there was room
in our lives for a kid which made it
made it kind of make sense I mean I
totally get that like in some ways
I am more prepared to be a mother than I
have ever been in my entire life and I
am also at a point where I am more
adamant about making that decision
exactly when I feel like it's right than
ever before and you know I did the
opposite yeah you know of a you and
Sarah
I moved from Indianapolis to New York so
so now I'm in Brooklyn in this you know
I mean it's a good apartment but listen
I'm born and raised Hoosier so for the
amount of money that I'm spending I
still even though I like my apartment
often look at it and just get mad at it
I don't like kick it or let you know or
something because I'm like all of this
money all of this money for a
one-bedroom apartment and you know it's
more like when I pay now and you know
rent is literally I'm not kidding you
literally five times what I paid when I
was living in Indianapolis to share a
four bedroom condo with two other people
and right yeah that doesn't surprise me
at all so it's so I'm very much you know
my boyfriend and I My partner and I
Kelly we are very much of the mind that
like yeah we might want to have kids at
some point but not here you know every
time every time we see somebody carrying
a stroller up the subway steps we're
like why why are you doing this dinner
so like there are places I promise where
you and it won't be like this like it
won't be this hard and kids in New York
just seems so jaded they're like at the
Museum of Natural History looking at
dinosaur bones like Oh again and I'm
just they're dinosaurs man and kids here
don't care about dinosaurs they're just
like I know they're all little Holden
Caulfield's that's how I felt when I
lived in New York I would always be like
oh that's they're just they're just the
sweetest little Holden Caufield
everywhere you look
but people people do have babies in
Brooklyn in fact like lots of the Lots
them so there are tons of strollers in
Brooklyn but yeah I feel I mean I think
the reason I feel the same way is
probably because I grew up you know in
in a suburban America and so when I
thought of having kids I imagined
lawns and neighborhoods and cookouts and
all the things that were part of my
childhood and so we never really
considered having kids when we lived in
New York although for the record lots of
people do it and do it very successfully
I have many friends who live in New York
and have kids and their kids are lovely
it just was never in the cards for us
but yeah I I do think there's an element
of it never being quite the right time
the other thing is that on occasion you
know the decision is made for you yeah
or in the case of Sara and I we thought
we had a ton of control over the timing
and then it turned out that of course
like we didn't so you know it there's an
there's an element of chance to it that
I don't know you can potentially work
that into your considerations but yeah I
think I think ultimately probably the
place to make that decision is not while
listening to the pod but while talking
to your partner I agree but it's just
one of those things where I'm glad to
see someone especially a woman exploring
you know their decision making when it
comes to having a baby like I'm really
glad to see a woman stopping and saying
wait like am I doing this because I want
to do it or am i doing it because it's
on a checklist and it's just the next
thing you know I heard so many women
friends from college you know who have
had babies at this point on purpose and
a couple who not on purpose
you know but you know they have these
babies and some of them are very much
like you know I had my baby I wanted to
have my baby and now I have them and
it's the best thing in the world and
others of them were like I wish I'd
waited I wish I didn't think that like
you know well I got married and then we
bought a house so now I happen to have
the baby you know and I'm glad to see
someone exploring that and really
thinking about what they actually want
and what family looks like for them
because not every family includes kids
and that's totally okay and you know
there are a lot of different ways to be
a family so start you know like I think
it's important that you know if you're
asking these self yourself these
questions to just keep asking them and I
think eventually the answer will come to
you I think at some point it does become
pretty clear whether you're gonna do it
or not
right and when that happens you know
it's just it's it's really comforting to
know that like this is not something I
rushed into and it's something that I
really thought about yeah no I think
that's a great point and I do think it's
really important for women to be able to
have those open conversations about
having kids bringing kids up not having
to pretend like it's always easy or
always fun or like the pressures
surrounding especially I think
motherhood don't exist because they do
and the social societal pressures are
really really intense yeah no doubt
about it someone who is a nanny as
someone who was a nanny for several
years I can tell you like the pressure
on moms is intense and and not so for
nannies okay Annie is like we can really
do whatever we want to be perfectly
honest like the kids I used to nanny I
still you know I go spend a couple days
with them before Christmas almost every
year every time I'm in Indiana I try to
go see them we all end up sleeping in
the same bed off the most fun in the
world but at the same time I'm so aware
I'm so aware that their mom has done so
much like so much and I just get to be
fun miss Ashley right shows up
and doesn't have to deal with like the
mommy politics so when I teach them to
say you know terrible things it's
because I can get away with that and
it's fun cuz it's miss Ashley but if mom
did it she'd be you know neglectful
right yeah all right Ashley I've got
another question for you this one comes
from Emma who writes Dear John and Hank
I was wondering why the space key on a
keyboard makes a different sound than
all the other keys is it due to its size
or perhaps is it due to the urgency with
which we finish our words and feel the
need to get on to the next one I'd like
to know because maybe I will now spend
my study hall doing work instead of
pondering this I think it's this is this
is a real thing it is let's just
establish that at the start it 100% is a
real thing I have thought about it a lot
I'm not kidding like the minute I read
that question I started thinking about
it and you know what I think it is I
think it's just I think it's the finger
that you hit the key with I feel I agree
I think it's I think it's the thumb
nosov it I think so too I think your
thumb is in my mind at least like your
heaviest finger because it's like stout
and kind of fat and like weird and also
that like when you hit at least when I
hit the space key I'm always hitting it
with the side and not even like the pad
of my finger right it's not a finger tip
the way you hit a J that you know I am
so there's actually a word for like the
way the keyboard feels when you push the
key action it's called the key action is
when you push down and it and the way
that that feels and how different it
feels on different keyboards and in my
early writing career I I have OCD but I
would argue that this isn't necessarily
a compulsive thing but I was very very
obsessive about key action and different
keyboards and this before I got a laptop
I kept the same keyboard through several
computers while I was writing Looking
for Alaska because
I felt very strongly that the key action
was what made it possible for me to
write well and when I would try other
keyboards I would be like no no no that
sounds all wrong that's extremely
distracting who could possibly write a
good novel with this terrible key fort
so I would just take the old keyboard
that I'd had since college and reinstall
it into the new computer and I
eventually got over that but I did use a
different keyboard for each book that I
wrote until the last five years until
until the end of The Fault in Our Stars
and and now I've decided to be a little
bit less specific about it but it is
it's so real the way the keys feel when
you're writing it so it's part of the
magic for me it's so real I still you
know I started writing on PCs and so
going to the map which obviously has
such a different key action from the P
total when you're on a Mac I hated it
like I immediately hated it like lo yeah
like what I would I used to we didn't
have a computer in our house until I was
really like either right before I went
to college or after I went to college
did we have well a computer in our home
but the library was very close to my
home and my brother and I used to walk
to the library all the time to use the
computers and I was the kid who would
sign up specifically for a PC computer
and I would wait like I well like they
would be like there are five max open
and I would be like I don't care I do
not care I will wait here don't mind me
I'm over here rereading this like
Lucille Ball biography and then and then
I'm going to walk over and do like my
thing on the computer which to be fair
was mostly like me writing stories about
my life
which were real but that I pretended to
you know fiction life and then looking
up to see if anybody was posting lyrics
from Kenny Loggins albums because I
loved them and I wanted to make sure I
was singing the words right but back
then not a lot of people were posting
Kenny Loggins lyrics on the internet so
yeah I mean you probably could have
cornered that market if only you'd had a
computer at home by launching the
definitive Kenny Loggins lyrics website
this is the thing that I find completely
fascinating about you you are an eye on
eclis deeply passionate about the songs
of Kenny Loggins like not even yeah like
not even funny like it's it's real it's
very yeah no it does it it's yeah and I
think I think it's great I am in favor
of people being super enthusiastic and
unembarrassed about the stuff that they
love oh yeah
whether that's Kenny Loggins albums or
anything
I've always people asked me this a lot
like I've had quite a few people who
have met me in person who first met me
on the internet and they'll be like you
are so much of who you are it's all the
same and I'm like oh I'm just like this
is not I'm just really bad at pretending
like super bad like I'm really terrible
at it like I can't keep it up the thing
is is that like I could you know have an
account online or you know wherever and
like sort of pretend to be a different
way for a little while and then I would
just be so exhausted that you'd be like
Ashley what's wrong with you like I
would be like a robot shutting down like
I would start to say things that didn't
make sense and you'd be like what's
happening and I would be like I was
pretending and I'm sorry I have to back
to being me now which means I'm gonna
like listen to celebrate me home a lot
and also means like you know the return
to poo corner album is my fave you know
I'm gonna watch Golden Girls a lot I'm
gonna watch The Nanny a lot it's like
these are just things that are part of
who I am and you know they're not
harmful so what do I have to hide I
guess
I think it's great and I think it
encourages everybody who has their weird
the weird thing that they love to love
it without any hesitation or
embarrassment and Emma that includes you
and your fascination with keyboards
which I am a hundred percent behind so
Ashley and I theorized that it is
because you are hitting the spacebar
with the side of your stoutest digit
that causes the thud but I will say I
don't think there is anything in my life
that I like more than when I'm writing
and it's going well and that sense of
it's almost like the rhythmic thud of
the spacebar is mistake you are driving
at night and that's this that's the
sight of those lane lines going past
your car or something it's just
tremendously fulfilling to hit that
spacebar and feel like you're moving I
imagine it's what people who write or
have written on typewriters a lot feel
when they hear that little like ding at
the end when there's like that thing
that's just like and then like it goes
back to the other side it's like wow
it's like another row how dare I be this
amazing like how dare I be this awesome
- like just hear all these dings while
I'm writing like I'm on fire over here
yeah yeah it's that feeling it's that
that's the feeling of like being on fire
and I totally agree with you about the
Mac keyboard being utterly suboptimal
when it comes to that feeling because
there's almost no key action in these
keys now there's almost none it feels
like like there's little pillows under
them or something and I'm like I don't
know
I don't want pillows under my keys man
like I want like I don't even want key
action I want key impact okay like I'm
here like I wanted to come together and
I want to like hear like the click click
click click like I need it so yeah
that's basically where we stand on these
keyboards I've frequently wondered if I
should just like do the thing where you
your Mac up on like a stand and then
have like your PC keyboard attached to
yeah you type yeah okay maybe I have
thought of doing that but then I think
like that when I went if people ask me
about that when I am explaining it I'm
going to seem like I'm totally out of
touch with reality but I'm really glad
to know that I'm not that you agree with
me about this on this be definitely
agree job questions from Isaiah who
asked sorry Ashley and I are laughing
it's something that you guys didn't get
to hear this question comes from Isaiah
who asks Dear John and Hank I'm worried
that I'm losing a very special skill for
years I've been a practitioner of jazz
music I've spent thousands of hours
studying theory practicing rehearsing
and jamming and even forming a spiritual
realization of music palaver as a young
person rising through the ranks I
quickly realized that music pays way
fewer bills than I ever imagined we all
know that musicians rarely make much
from records nowadays but at least in
Chicago venues don't pay for live shows
either I've sold all my tickets to House
of Blues twice on Friday nights and went
home with zero dollars I was lucky
enough to make it into Evanston Illinois
his most famous University which by the
way Isiah counts my wife among their
alumni to study biology which I enjoy I
make a modest living with a low ceiling
as a teacher however the feeling of
being me felt different when I was
better at jazz I haven't completely
stopped playing but without spending
hours on it each day I feel rusty and I
wonder if I spend my whole life feeling
rusty I know it's a hard one because
this is a this is a true fact of being a
an artist or making things for a living
or performing for a living which is that
many times it isn't your living yeah
yeah it's really hard to do that and you
know that's not you know that's not
Isaiah's fault
that's no artists thought for the most
part the the biggest fault is that you
know people tend to devalue work that is
enjoyed while it is being made
so it's like it really liked it then why
am I paying you for it and that's
unfortunate and I I think that's sort of
you know the wrong way to go but it is
kind of the way things are right now and
it's hard it's hard but when you love
something and you study it and you
devote all this time to it and then feel
like you can't maintain that level of
expertise or that level of production or
you know whatever but at the same time
you know I I think sometimes we have to
shift our idea of what art is for and I
think that while we want to be experts
and we want to be people who are always
at the top of our game in art that you
have to make a decision
somewhere along the line about whether
or not that's something that you can
actually do and also whether or not
that's something you can sustain and
it's just such a hard question and it's
so private I think really person yeah I
mean it is it is very much like a
case-to-case thing I mean I come at this
from an incredibly privileged position
because I've been able to make a living
writing for a long time now I mean for
the first several years that I was
writing and even when I was writing
semi-professionally I didn't but but I
have for the last you know nine nine or
10 years but I do have maybe like an
analogous experience in the sense that
after my book The Fault in Our Stars
came out for a long time I wasn't
writing because I was doing other things
because there was movie stuff happening
and our crash course channel was taking
off educational video channel that Hank
and I started and and then also because
writing became on fun and I started to
feel rusty and I started to feel like I
wasn't good at it
anymore and like maybe I was never gonna
be good at it again and there are lots
of examples of this happening like it's
not an irrational fear you know
I mean there there's famous stories of
people who were among the best golfers
in the world for instance and one day
they picked up their clubs and found
that they could no longer play golf well
there's a exam very famous example of a
baseball player who made three straight
throwing errors in the major leagues
after a very successful major league
career and never again was able to play
Major League Baseball Mike just was
never able to do it again never could
complete the throws and and of course
like in the case of writing there's lots
and lots and lots and lots of examples
of people like that from you know
wonderful writers who had very
successful careers like Harper Lee to
many many writers out there like
including my great uncle who wrote one
novel and then found it impossible to
write another whether it was the first
one was successful or not
so I did I started to feel rusty and I
also felt like it was something that I
could never do again or never never
enjoy again I found though for me that
by keeping at it and by continuing to
try to write that it got better I didn't
stop feeling rusty and I still probably
think that and I'm not well I'll just
say this I still do probably think that
my best writing is is behind me in a lot
of ways but I have I was it what I found
was an ability to enjoy writing again
because I stopped making it about
wanting to be the best or wanting to be
better than some past version of myself
or better than other people I admire a
lot who write why a fiction are better
than this or better than that and
instead of seeing it as like a pyramid
or something that you're trying to get
to the top of I started seeing it as a
huge ball that I'm trying to like
contribute one layer of paint to and
lots and lots of other people are
contributing layers of paint and through
that the ball gets more beautiful and
interesting and also bigger
and and instead of me being needing to
be like at the top of my game somehow
what I can really do I think in the end
is contribute in a small way to a very
big conversation that's very old and and
that's what art is for me I mean so many
you know like my fears as a writer as a
performer and as someone who you know
needs to make a living are so wrapped up
and a lot of you know those same
thoughts and those same you know like
the rustiness and the you know what if I
have already done the best thing I'm
ever going to do and I think you know as
someone who has a day job somebody who
has a place that she has to be you know
like every day even though even even in
terms of like day jobs I'm still kind of
sitting pretty because I have unlimited
vacation at my job and also you know
they understand that I'm a writer and do
other things and you know allow me room
and space to do those things which is
not true for everybody or even most
people who have day jobs but you know I
have a lot of those fears that by having
a stay job or you know by doing things
that are not just sitting down and
writing that I'm not being a good writer
and that I won't ever be a better writer
because of those things you know but
sometimes I'm like you know some things
you just they're important and they are
part of living a full and whole life as
an artist mm-hmm and that's important
not just for your art but also for the
way you experience the world in general
like at the end of the day we're people
you know and we might be artists people
but we are still people and people have
to eat and people have to have somewhere
to live
and people have to have you know certain
things to feel you know comfortable and
feel like they can get to a place where
they can even create in the way that
they want to you know so I don't know I
guess I'm just saying that you know I
feel like tonight I should be working on
my book
but instead I'm interviewing Zadie Smith
you know and that does not that sounds
pretty great actually right but my point
is like that doesn't feel like being
less of a writer that doesn't feel like
being less of an artist that doesn't
feel like I'm throwing away some future
and I think I think that the key to art
that we forget sometimes is joy and you
know you talking about finding the joy
and being able to enjoy writing again I
think I I don't think that the problem
with Isaiah is that you know because he
can't spend hours a day he'll never be
happy I think he sort of has to redefine
why and how music gives him joy and why
how and why playing music gives him you
know space to feel like more of himself
or the person that he wants to be yeah I
think that's exactly right
and I think ultimately the conclusion
that I've come to about writing is that
regardless of whether I ever publish
anything again writing helps me feel
like myself
it helps me it is it's like it's it's
joyful for me
it's the only it's kind of the only time
that for me that I can get lost enough
in something I feel this occasionally
when I read when I can get lost enough
in something that I feel like I can
escape myself for a minute which is very
joyful thing like it to me it's sort of
terrifying the thought of being stuck
inside of one one consciousness for for
decades and decades I couldn't do it I
could do it I'm already I already have a
hard time just like you know I tried
meditating and meditating sounds so
awesome in theory and I really want to
do it because I really want
be the kind of person who can do it and
every time I'm just like well it is like
it's not safe in here
I can't job you in here like for ten
minutes I totally agree it is not safe
video and you know maybe that's its own
problem maybe I should be talking to
somebody more about that but you know I
mean I completely agree with you and I
know that I'm I'm actually having to
meditate every day because of this new
health and fitness show that I'm doing
on YouTube youtube.com slash 100 days
never not self promo Inc and it's not
going great and lots of people are
telling me oh you're just meditating
wrong and I'm like you know what
criticizing my meditation is also not
helpful
like that's not that's also not getting
me to where I need to be right now like
because before when I wasn't meditating
at all I was happier and now with you
criticizing my meditation on top of not
enjoying the meditation you're making
everything worse everything's worse now
thanks for nothing meditation like it is
not going well and boy did I give it my
best shot but you know what there are
other things to master in this world and
I should probably move along this one
just ain't for me I talked to my friend
Josh Sundquist about meditation he's a
big advocate for it and he was like oh I
didn't see any much improvement at all
in the first year and I was like I can't
do something for a year where I don't
see any improvement I can just barely
brush my teeth every day for a year like
knowing that there are real risks to not
like there's no way I'm gonna be able to
put in the time necessary to get these
rewards
I got like I'm so with you on this and
it's like a thing about myself that
infuriates me about myself but also it's
like I just have to know that that's
true I
just spent a lot of money on a personal
trainer who I've seen like four times
and now I'm kind of like I think I got
all I needed out of that I think I'm the
kind of person who personally trains you
know after just like a few sessions
because I was like hmm not really losing
any weight here uh yeah I don't really
feel better people were like your
Energy's gonna get better and I was like
nah I've just been sleeping more so no
I'm okay yeah I mean you really do I I
have found benefits to exercise but it
is totally true that they are not
immediate but yeah I'm well but I don't
just take care of yourself in whatever
ways you can find we should move on to
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
Ashley I know this is your favorite part
of the podcast and also the listeners
just kidding nobody likes it
the news from Mars I looked up some news
for Mars for you people it was
physically painful I did not enjoy it
Mars is a boring cold rock and the
vastness of space it doesn't matter
however since Hank is not here I didn't
look up some news from Mars
and they've just found a depression on
Mars not caused by the election but
caused by a crater at the edge of the
helis Basin which is surrounded by
glacial deposits and is near to another
similar depression and the nature of
this depression is such that it has it
was likely a place where life would have
formed if life indeed formed on Mars so
they now know a place that they can go
look for life on Mars if and when
anybody ever gets to Mars which will
hopefully not have until 2028 because if
it doesn't happen until 2028 we get to
rename this podcast Dear John and Hank
which is my dearest dream I don't know
that is the news from Mars I don't know
John I think post-election people might
be speeding up there Mars I am concerned
I'm not saying I'm concerned true I'm
not saying that I heard rumors but yeah
I am saying that I live in New York City
and talk gets around okay and I am
saying that you know Mars is looking
better and better every day John and
that's not a personal opinion I I think
no no yeah yeah I am concerned I think
that this election was very bad for my
ability to make sure that humans are an
earth only species until at least 20 28
so I can get this podcast renamed
alright so there is also news from AFC
Wimbledon the third tier English soccer
team sponsored by nerdfighteria owned by
their fans who've worked their way up
all the way from the ninth tier of
English football now to the third tier
they played the FA Cup yesterday which
is a competition that the old Wimbledon
actually won once and they beat a team
called berry bu ry as in we buried them
we beat them five to nothing
we scored five goals in just 90 minutes
when we won five to nothing who scored
the goals freaking everybody everybody
scored it was it was amazing
Paul Robinson scored a goal Dom Polian
scored a goal the the Montserrat E and
Messi
Lyle Taylor scored a goal the the the
leading scorer of on Montserrat's
national football team Lyle Taylor
scored a goal as well it was just it was
a beautiful beautiful game five nothing
victory
you can watch the highlights on YouTube
the YouTube highlight reel is like 17
minutes long because it's just the goals
just kept coming
yeah it was great that means that we're
going to the second round of the FA Cup
where we're gonna play a team in the 6th
tier we that the draw has already
happened and it's I want to give you the
name because I know that I know how much
this matters to everybody the name of
the team is kurzon Ashton and if we win
that game
we will then
get to the third round of the FA Cup
where we could potentially play like
Manchester United or Chelsea or
something which would be incredibly
exciting and also quite lucrative
John what I know yeah I know I know okay
great
the last time I looked up stuff about
AFC Wimbledon I was actually super
shocked at their ranking in the third
tier but I had a great but I I know
which was like they were only like I
think last time I looked they had 17
points but now things have gotten even
better things have gotten even better
for AFC Wimbledon which makes me very
happy because I decided to get into a
club soccer a little bit over the past
two years which was heavily influenced
by your enthusiasm so I don't know a
little bit of a little bit but here's my
question that you know I'm like I'm
wondering what does it mean if AFC
Wimbledon were to be a Manchester United
I mean it would be it would be like in
the scheme of things like probably
nothing because then they were just in
the next round draw another team like
Manchester United that would presumably
at some point beat them yeah but in of
course like in the in the long run
nothing matters you know if you want to
really zoom out like nothing matters in
football or or in anything else so so
you don't want to zoom all the way out
right like I want to live in the moment
and in the moment it would be ridiculous
like it would be that it would be the it
would just be it would be so beautiful
especially if it was Manchester United
the team I hate most in the whole world
except maybe Chelsea if it were
Manchester United or Chelsea it would
feel so good especially Chelsea because
they also play in South London so like
there's sort of rivals with AFC
Wimbledon but of course Chelsea has
never paused to consider AFC Wimbledon
that's a rifle that would feel pretty
great but that's why
their butt kicked yeah totally totally
yeah they need to be reminded that that
there's another team in South London
that's coming for them that's the thing
it's like sometimes you don't need to
win all the games you just need them to
know you're coming like you just need to
know that like hey I'm around yeah you
see them to be just oh just the thought
of them being aware of you is
tremendously fulfilling you know like
the thought of them having to worry
about it
having to be like oh gosh which of our
players who make $200,000 a week are we
gonna start against AFC Wimbledon great
yeah that's how I feel about my enemies
personally I'm not really trying to like
do anything to them I just need them to
know I'm around there is something
tremendously fulfilling about your
enemies worrying about you yeah I only
have two but should I ever acquire more
enemies I hope not I don't really like
having enemies because then you have to
think about them and that seemed it's
stressful it's stressful and wasteful
there are so many things to be thinking
about in the world and just like enemies
seems like the worst thing to have to
think about except like going to the
dentist which you know does seem like a
pretty you know like like a like not
like a waste but definitely like I wish
I didn't have to think about that
I feel like enemies are the same way
like I just wish I never had to think
about my two enemies who are also both
in their 70s so maybe they're in their
70s yeah oh so I mean obviously I'm not
gonna not gonna ask you to name them
because that gives your enemies power
they may not want to give them that
power I got I love your chances about
living them great I mean not just based
on like age but also based on like
general wilderness survival skills of
which I have many and they have certain
and so I just like I feel like no matter
what happens I'm still probably going
to outlive them because of my like just
because my just because of my wilderness
skills and also because of my general
youth which is you know just slipping
slipping by the day I'll be 30 in June
you know oh you're so young to be so
young I'm glad to know though that in
the like post social order collapse mr.
robot future that we're all headed for
your your wilderness survival skills are
going to come in handy because I will be
knocking on the door of your tent you
can totally come through you and your
fam listen my boyfriend is really great
with a bow and arrow
I oh wow great I'm great at sewing and
cooking and building fires I was a boy
scout post high school so I just learned
a bunch because that's what I do I'm an
information junkie and then I just would
practice it sometimes because I'm just
I'm also an anxiety junkie and so every
once a while like this whole structure
this whole like civilized like society
note could come crashing down any minute
I got to be ready I got to be so I agree
that it's a it's exceptionally fragile
but I haven't done a good job preparing
I am a reasonably astute starter of
fires so perhaps that can be the way
that I contribute yes you're in you're
in the club all my club is a lighter and
a Duraflame okay well Ashley thank you
so much for being on the podcast with me
this has been an unadulterated joy I
want to tell everybody to follow you on
Twitter to keep up with all the things
that you're doing even though you are
taking and I think this is very smart
the remainder of November off from
Twitter might be back sooner though for
my job because I might be taking a road
trip like an interesting little road
trip that
requires my Twitter usage so we'll see
we'll see that sounds exciting
but yeah so you can follow Ashley on
Twitter at I smash fizzle i SMA sh fi z
z la nope
fi ZZ Ellie I'm really bad at spelling
it's just the exact way that you would
think I smashed fizzle is spelled ya
know it's so phonetic it's very very
easy it's not a challenging Twitter
handle to spell you can also find me on
Twitter at John Green Joh ngr aan and
you can send us emails at Hank and John
at gmail.com that's all one word Hank
and John at gmail.com yeah so you can
you can be in contact with us and we
will try to answer as many of your
questions as possible I apologize to all
the people who we didn't answer your
questions I also want to apologize to
all the Trent's out there because in a
recent episode of the podcast Hank used
the word the name Trent as an example of
a millennial name I made fun of Hank for
that several Trent's felt that that was
a bit of a personal sleight so I just
want to say to all the Trent's out there
just because you almost certainly aren't
a millennial doesn't mean that there's
anything wrong with your lovely name and
I am sorry if I implied otherwise and in
fact if you are a millennial I am sorry
about implying that you weren't if you
want to be a millennial which seems like
a dubious proposition to me but whatever
it's your life
Ashley thank you so much though for for
for parting with me this is this has
been a joy so much fun for me this is a
little bit of a dream come true
because I love listening to the pod and
being on it just makes me feel like even
more of an awesome well I will say
nothing ruins this podcast quite like
having to listen to your own voice on it
so look forward to that pleasure again
you can write us at Hank Ajanta
gmail.com our podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins Victoria helps out with
questions as does rosianna halse rojas
thanks to everybody for listening and to
gunnarolla for doing our theme music and
as we say in my hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]